so thank you very much
for joining this session on privacy
preserving
ai discovery platform we're very happy
to be part of the
biome journey launch today thanks to our
host
christian don michelle and mila
and the support of joshua bengio in
imagia's mission
i will tell you a short secret before we
start the presentation
before mila was actually named mila
it was named lisa so i'm very happy
today to co-host you with my colleague
lisa de giorio she's the director
of ai research and in our team we call
it open innovation
so i'm alexander busley i'm the
co-founder and ceo
of imagia and today we're gonna discuss
about
how can we apply different ai
techniques to really do those discovery
in an
ethical way while maintaining ip
protection so at the end of this
presentation
you'll learn three key principles that
we're going to apply by design
in this discovery platform and we'll
have the the chance
of having a key panelist to discuss
the potential application of artificial
intelligence
those panelists have been selected very
carefully
typically they do keynotes in events
so we feel very honored to have them i'm
going to present them
at the end of the presentation but
really thank them for your time
in this precious day
as you know the healthcare data have
really exploded
in the last seven years and the trend is
is not stopping we have iot we have more
and more device
that produce data on a daily basis
with all those data you could imagine
that we would be better
but still we're there's a lot of way
to go to reduce the rate of misdiagnosed
cases and also we are very far
from having response to treatment that
are reaching 100 percent
so we really want to impre improve the
patient journey
because in high burden disease the clock
is always
ticking artificial intelligence
have made a lot of progress and i'm
going to show you
a very interesting image
and i really want to have your
input on that image some people will say
this looks like a medical image this
looks like a ct image but
in fact this is not a medical image this
was a computer generated image
a computer dream in a sense we train
an ai model with a lot of normal
ct scan and we extracted
imaging feature uh using adversarial net
a type of adversarial network
to represent what is normality so this
is really a synthetic
data so that serve that purpose but also
it serve us
to better understand what is normality
so you can extract data from
high volumes of you can extract insights
from high volumes of data and produce
some interesting
synthetic data essentially
what we want to do from a digital
discovery perspective
is really accelerate the healthcare
innovation
and how do we want to do that is first
by the data
if you ask yeshua if you ask every ai
scientist
you want more data so you want to make
sure that you
you have access to the right data in the
right quantity
with the right metadata information and
we'll discuss that later
you want to get artificial intelligence
inside
in a easy way in an autonomous way and
you want to also expand
on collaboration because you don't want
just to work on your data set
otherwise you'll end up with a discovery
that is biased
and this is a very important concept in
artificial intelligence
we want to discover those links between
the data
that can help treatment optimization
that can help
response prediction and can build
clinical decision support system
and all those digital discovery will
really transform
the digital medicine as we know and we
will be brought to life to patient
by industry leaders such as novartis
as you know there are many problems in
applying ai
but also ai can be a solution by itself
so we know we have data in silo
it's difficult to get insights from all
those data
we have network privacy issue more and
more
it's very present we have pipe dala in
canada we have gdpr we have hipaa
we want to make sure that we respect
privacy of data
and you want to make sure that whatever
digital solution you come up with
will really reach clinical adoption
because you want to reach patient
so those different problems can be
seen as a challenge but could also be
seen as an opportunity
to help and apply artificial
intelligence
to gather the data to get more insight
we'll discuss today how we can solve
partially
the network privacy issue and if we can
empower the clinicians to build their
own solution
we'll get better chance at clinical
adoption
so i'm going to refer to the montreal
declaration of responsible ai
which is one of the most sought of
declaration
in the world by mit they did an
extensive review
of multiple declaration and this
declaration essentially have 10
principles
i'm going to focus on three key
principles
autonomy privacy and diversity
and you'll see how those are important
and how can we apply
those principles by design in a software
in a platform to make sure that they're
not only
principles but they cannot be violated
because they're
hard coded in the platform
what those principles are so the first
one
we thought for a long time that patient
data privacy
and making discovery were opposing
concepts
we think not and this is what we're
going to discuss today we can
respect patient data privacy while
making discovery
the second principle is regarding
diversity
so when you make a model it's an ai
model it's really important that you get
data from
different sources different equipment
provider
different mode of acquisition different
treatment protocols
otherwise your data and your model are
biased
so it's really important to capture data
across
multiple centers to capture that
diversity
finally autonomy um
we want to empower clinicians so they
can do the discovery by themselves and
we want to empower them
with ai technology and today
ai scientists don't do ai model
they build technology that are building
with the help of artificial intelligence
automatically those models so today
we're going to introduce you two
concepts that were discussed today
federated learning and self-evolving ai
in our platform imagia evidence
and to that end i gave the talk to lisa
desjardins my colleague thanks alex
for this uh introduction so i will cover
um a bit more in detail the techniques
that allows us to
achieve a privacy or at least to address
the challenge of privacy into machine
learning
roughly we could classify them into
three
major pockets the first one is what we
call
centralized learning one very good
example of it
is federated learning you might have
heard about it because lately it's the
one that got the much
the most attention from the media
here in a nutshell you trust a central
server to aggregate knowledge that was
locally extracted i'm going to go back
to that technique in more detail within
the next slide
another set of techniques is pretty much
the same
mindset except you would like to just
get rid of the central server so
is there any way or any techniques that
could exist such as you
can still extract your knowledge locally
so without sharing your data
and pass on the knowledge extracted a
very good example of this in
the research community right now is
continual learning
where the goal is really to learn
new knowledge from a local data set
without forgetting any other
knowledge that was learned by previous
part and
the last set of techniques i would say
will tend to act a bit more on the data
so alex showed an example of
fake data generated data so there could
be a solution where you
try to extract the data distribution and
attributes
generate fake patient and contribute
this patient to a central database
other methods that are really well known
within the machine learning community
tend to add noise to the data to prevent
indeed individual identification
while you are still able to learn the
major property of this data set these
techniques are called
differential privacy so if you want to
go to the next slide please
so how does federated learning works
namely you have a central server the one
that alexis is
currently highlighting in gray that will
be in charge of aggregating knowledge
but not in charge of seeing or
manipulating or even
accessing to any data the data will stay
locally at the collaborator
side so here in this example we have
five different collaborators
this could be hospital or center
but they wish to collaborate and
discover
a joint model without
sharing any data so the server will
initialize a model send this model to
every collaborator as a first part every
collaborator will learn and trend this
model
locally on their own data set so somehow
they are extracting the knowledge of the
data
and they will send it back to the
central server so here
the server will receive five different
models
it will be in charge of aggregating them
by doing so
the local model are not that accurate as
previously
so the server will send back this model
towards the collaborator who will train
again
and so on this is called a round and the
goal is to make as much friend
as needed until the knowledge the
training converge
so if you want to go to the next slide
thanks
within this framework there is different
kind of scenario that could happen
the first one that is called horizontal
federated learning
is when you have different collaborators
who do not share
any common samples so here the sample
could be the patient so
a patient goes either to hospital a or
hospital b
but not to both of them and every center
extract the exact same kind of attribute
so here
we could say that both hospital a and b
provide the model with ct scan and
clinical information
when it's the opposite it's called
federating
learning so in that scenario
patient can go both to hospital a
and hospitality but those hospitals each
extract different kind of information
from the expression so for example
hospital a could still
extract ct and clinical information
whereas hospital b
will provide the model with genetic
information
the last scenario is when you have
a mix of both so few patients are
overlapping and few attributes are
also overlapping in that case we will
call it federated transfer learning and
we will rely on what we call
transfer learning technique so transfer
learning is really interesting
in the framework of federated learning
in a nutshell the technique consists of
training
on a data set and then using the train
model on a different data set
to uh start from the knowledge that was
learned previously
we call that part fine tuning at imager
we invested
a bit on this method and we found new
way to optimize this transfer learning
technique
and when we applied this within the
federated learning
framework we realized that they really
do make a difference so for example what
you see on the right is
an example of application of transfer
learning optimization
at the moment of the transfer from the
aggregated model towards the
local model at each run and what you can
see
is that the final learning is
faster and on top of it more accurate
this is the orange line
whereas the blue line is the base line
so if you want to go to the next slide
finally something and some other way to
ensure privacy by design is as alex
mentioned to provide the clinician with
autonomy so
we will provide them with a way of
creating automatically or generating
automatically their model
from their data set train locally still
and when they are happy
with this model propose to other parts
to collaborate
and to federate this model so you see an
example of this technique on the right
what you can see on the two
architecture the first one and the
second one are human
design architecture on the third
part this is what our method will
generate so you can see that it's really
different from what a human being
would do and this is this exact same
model that was
in that example federated
on the bottom we can see the result of
it and what we can see is that
we still obtain a very good accuracy the
task here was a medical task a module
detection
from ct scans so that's
it for me thanks alex
thank you very much liza it's a pleasure
of working with you since the last five
years
um so where we are with those technology
we are currently deploying in quebec
digital discovery platform in five
hospital
currently we've completed the deployment
of this first
iteration in three hospital uh the
platform have access to one million
patient data that is being indexed those
patient data
does not leave the hospital and only
projects that are
ethically approved by erb committees
can actually do the work but all the
legal framework
all the i.t framework all the security
framework
have been completed out of three out of
five hospital
and of course when those five hospitals
will be completed
we'll be very happy the type of data
that we
are accessing are on a project basis
most of the project need images need
reports
needs demographic and also ehr data so
diagnostic
treatment response and results so
anything that goes to the hl7 feed we're
able to capture
so we're essentially capturing the real
world data
and what we want to accomplish with our
technology is transform
those real-world data into real-world
evidence
as automatically as possible in a
much automated fashion and currently
we're integrating
oncology genomic and virtual pathology
data
on a pre-project basis
we want not to remain in quebec because
quebec wants to collaborate
with other jurisdictions so we're
expanding across
the country and we're very proud to
co-lead a 200 million initiative
with the terry fox research institute
that was launched
three weeks ago in what we call a
digital health and discovery
platform the hdp dot ca it's really a
fusion
of high burden disease of course cancer
first
in the ai communities and as you see in
the diagram it's really a collaboration
model
where we have the patient in the middle
that involves public and partner
public and private partner including the
mila
including novartis with a high focus on
cancer
and starting with the second disease
area neuro
so people have been talking about the
data trust we think that distributed
data trust
is a better suitable approach because it
gives the local control of what people
want to do with their data
including the patients we also want to
make sure that
non-ai experts can benefit from all the
work of the ai institutions
and also the companies such as imagia
that brings
ai technology to them
finally we're expanding that platform so
all those researchers will be able to
collaborate with other researchers and
other data
in the united states talking starting
with upenn
and in france starting with bio valley
and i just put some few logos here but
as you understand the hdp is already 97
partners including novartis
so we really want to grow that network
of partner
to make sure that together we can make a
difference
so that being said the ecosystem cannot
be complete
which without you we really want to be a
part of your thought process
if you're a clinician if you are part of
a government
in hospital an ai research institution
a pharma a medical device or another
commercial partner that do ai
we want to partner together to make sure
that this two-sided platform
the producer and the consumer really
work collaboratively together
for the benefit of the patient
and now we're moving to the very
interesting part
and it's a privilege to introduce the
the four panelists
they come i would say from four
geographies and they will bring four
perspectives
on this ai topics we have about 25
minutes for the questions and of course
after
we'll take questions from the audience
so the first
panelist is a doctor fabrice grenade
he's the ceo of the schum which was the
largest hospital in construction in
north america with a budget of
3.5 billion dollar and in quebec we're
very tight on budget we made sure that
the construction was on
time i think it was a great success and
you see the image on the right
fabrice has been highly decorated and he
has received a french
legion of honor for his career in
healthcare
he's a top leader uh he implemented
within the shroom
the first ai medical school in the world
and i'm very proud to say that i have
co-authored with joshua benjio
a short ai chapter in his latest book on
healthcare innovation you see the
picture on the right of the book
so you have a great admiration and
friendship for fabrice
and for everything that he's doing for
his 12 000 employees and not counting
all the patients that goes to shem
second panelist paula schweck has been
tasked with
one of the most noble initiative making
sure that
innovation will thrive in quebec so
that's not an easy feat
he was the ceo of genome quebec for
eight years so i'm sure he knows about
genomics
and he has extensive experience in the
private pharmaceutical sector
so i think it's really important to have
both a
side of the story and from your you know
inaugural speech as the first innovation
director
i knew that the choice was the right one
we also have the privilege of having
professor lepage
and we have deployed the platform
in the sherbrooke so he will talk about
his experience and now he sees the
expansion
about using techniques such as federated
learning as part of the deployment
he is the co-director of the quebec
bioimaging network
and he will have the honor to discuss
about insight that he got in his
hospital
finally we have professor francois
dialept
he's the founding director of the
university level big data research
center
which brings together no less than 65
senior researchers from six faculties uh
working together he holds
two chairs in interpretable ai so that's
a very important topic
for the conversation of course we want
to bring ai discovery
but it's important to explain them and
understand them
so i'm counting on you francois to give
a highlight on that
uh we met before the creation of obvia
i'll talk briefly on that
and we're looking forward to expand our
mutual collaboration
so all those four panelists typically do
keynote speech at events so i'm very
humbled to be with you today and we'll
start with the first
question so feel free to unmute your
microphone
it's an open discussion we we want to
discuss
on the importance of data privacy uh
as well as protecting vip from an
organization whether it's a hospital
or a private company i think both are
important
but we have the patient in mind so how
do we work
paul maybe i'll get started then
alexandre thanks for your
kind words and i'm very pleased to
participate to this
to this panel i think this discussion is
coming at a very
good time because i think the the
covid pandemic has created an
environment which is
uh which is a different environment and
some of the statue quote that we were
relying on and
almost uh attaching ourselves to uh
is now moving and we're seeing a change
in attitude and
some of the issues related to privacy
and to
ip protection but more around privacy
are certainly evolving and it's not that
it's not important
it's not that patient and consumers
won't be at the center of that
but it is a more the fact that we're
starting to
see the uh the need the the absolute
need to
to get moving on those issues and and
from that standpoint
many different initiatives are uh
happening that
are providing light at the end of the
tunnel if i can express myself like that
some of them are known and they very
well recognize
our ability to move towards more
more integration of innovations
especially on the telemedicine side
and on the t uh using uh
information technology as well so those
are
important move but more fundamentally at
the
ministry of health and and with
colleagues with
from other ministries work is happening
on
uh how do we how do we ensure a
valorization of the data
and here is from the perspective of
making sure we're
extracting value from the data and
for all people that wants to extract
value from the data
so this uh this is a very very
fundamental
and important initiative uh we we know
that we need to
do something with the with our i.t
park and the tools we've got available
and we're working on that
as well there's work on the legislative
front which is happening from
all of those aspects i i think that we
can
see that we are very
carefully looking at this issue of
privacy and how do we ensure
the protection of the privacy but at the
same time how do we make data available
to do research to do management and to
do discovery in applications
what do you want to react to that and
add the uh the perspective of uh avia
and yours yeah of course uh i think that
uh yeah paul is right about that i think
that
data privacy is something that is very
very important
and the citizen must be in in the loop
we cannot do it
in in in in
in our isolated lab and say well
we will do it properly we have to be
totally
um transparent about that uh especially
for
uh for uh i would say one big reason is
the zero risk is not existing
usually people think that if we
de-anonymize
the data then there is no problem about
privacy
but this is absolutely not true we know
now that we can with the
the the power of ai we can do something
to
re uh to to to get some
information out of a anonymized data
we can even get some information about
people specific people just looking at
a neural net that has been learned on
data so this is very important to
to be understood the zero risk is not
existing
on the other side if you don't give
any data to ai you will have no
result at all so this is a very
important tradeoff that we have to deal
with now
and this is something that is in
in going in the reflection of people for
the from the government
and people from the research people from
industries and so on
and i think we have to be very careful
to how we do that
and and for example i think that the
federated learning
that has been proposed here is is
i think up to now the best proposition
that we can have
the deja is not moving from the secure
place
where it has been gathered the hospital
for example
the uh the researcher or the company
do not see the the data only the
the algorithm is seeing the data and
then we
gather the information back
i think this is the best compromise that
we can have
but again this the rx is not existing
we can manage to take the
neural network that has been learned
federated way
and get some influencer about people
it's
just much more difficult than
it has then for other methods
so for that i think yeah people has to
be
we have to be transparent with the
people and we have to
to care about getting the
the best way of doing things and we have
to understand
how to decide what is the trade-off
between the importance of the discovery
that
we can expect if we accept
that ai look at those these
data and the privacy uh risk
and this knowledge of the tradeoff is
something that we still have to learn i
think
thank you francois for bringing those
two perspective and i think the patient
consent
uh is is key there um
at the i see time flying so we're gonna
move to the second question we can
continue all day
on this important question the important
is to
move forward um i think we have a sound
solution
uh and as you say francoise the data
stays where it is
it's uh it's probably uh
the best risk that you can that we can
accept and manage
and i have so sure in imagine
thank you for mentioning that i would
say nobody
on the on the call have except lisa and
i
have interest in imagia and for people
to understand
when we talk about patient data
nobody wants to have the liability of
having
the actual nominative information even
even a pharma we want to get the
discovery we don't want
the raw data so this is a change of mind
that we're getting with the the data
transformation in quebec
we've been very good in the past in
selling or natural resource
it's better to sell a finished product
and a discovery
so moving to the second question
we would want to to know what are the
organizational barriers
to enable large federated learning
discovery process
so i know for example martin you
experienced the first iteration of
imagia evidence platform in your
institution so it was not set up
currently to do
federated learning but let's see some of
the process that you
are doing if you have the capability to
expand your human collaboration because
it needs to be human first
each ethical committee from each
hospitals need to approve that
but um there's probably other barriers
than technical
to do uh those large-scale discovery so
martin feel free to
comment thank you very much alexander
first for inviting me to this panel
and for this very relevant question uh
yeah my experience with the
evidence platform was very satisfactory
again i'm not played by imagia right he
said it i don't have any conflict of
interest i'm just saying what i think
um and uh it to me if you want to
enable collaboration then people must be
able to use a system
quite easily and what i saw is that you
could browse the packs you could select
patients
you could perform analysis you could see
the results all in this particular one
platform so if that did not exist then
you would have to
get the images from one software
annotate them in one software
maybe a different software and then
aggregate this data somewhere else
and this would just be impossible to do
exactly the same process
at different centers so having one piece
of software that does it all
and that would be the same everywhere
would make it a lot easier for people to
use and then to share
the knowledge acquired through your
system
now you talk about the barriers one of
the one of the barriers i think will be
encountered
quite quickly is the fact that although
i fully support that you want to include
diversity
in your uh in in in the data
you'll get diversity too much diversity
in the sense that you have different
vendors
making imaging instruments imaging
instruments for example for mri come in
different versions 1.5 tesla three
teslas some
have even seven tesla machines all of
these give
for the same patient would give
different images
and then there are protocols there's a
diversity of protocols that clinicians
use
in one or the other center that will
produce
images that are not exactly the same
they'll be pleasing the eye
of the radiologist or the radiation
oncologist or the neurologist that
prescribed
the exam but they may not be exactly the
same from one side to another
so when it comes to learning from these
images
i've seen examples and i'm not saying
this is your case but i'm seeing
examples of
uh ai algorithms that were extremely
good
at identifying from which vendors the
the images came but not so much at i
define you know
predicting the outcome of the patient so
this is an issue that needs to be
addressed
and i know you're working on it and it's
going to be extremely important because
uh
for those mri experts listening a t2
weighted for me is not a teacher waited
for you
is not the same teacher waited for
someone else so they all look a little
different
and then aggregating these this
knowledge might be
a barrier so i'll stop here but i'm
happy to comment further if
if need be thank you martin we briefly
touch on that
um let's bring the importance of
metadata so when data is acquired
it's really important to have the
combination of both ai scientists and
medical expert in that case mri expert
that can tell
the ai experts be careful what you see
in that field of dicom
will have an impact so that dialogue is
really important when
building the the research project i see
francois raising his hand
yeah i think that it's important that
everybody look at
wikipedia on the the the
what is fair data right
the fair principle meaning f is for
findability a is for accessibility
i is for interoperability and r is for
reusability
okay these principles are very the key
if we want to do
proper machine learning out of data
the reusability for example you have to
think that well
when it's time to to ask for the content
maybe it's not for only one research
that or one clinical
problem that we want to use the data of
this person maybe
it can be reused for other under
of course specific concerns that are
really careful carefully defined
this is why i say the citizen has to be
in the loop
but the fair ideas are important here
and the the the second point is the
importance to
have the possibility of sharing
expertise
to to to be able to collect the data and
to protect the data
properly and this is something that is
in quebec we are thinking about that
saying that well
there are some big uh hospitals like the
shum
that has a lot of resources but if you
look at the small clinic
then they cannot do the same kind of
[Music]
thing so if we want to to have fairly
learning among every every member of the
of the
health community we have to think that
we have to help
technically uh the people from
everywhere so and so this is
two two very important thing i think
thank you francoise question in the q a
one of them is about patient consent of
course when we do
large federated learning approach how
would you do that
if there's no consent there is the
the answer is if there is no consent you
cannot work on the data
so new technology will not change the
way
we are typically doing things ethically
so it's really important that
there's always a consent feel free to
ask other questions in a q a we'll
answer them
at the end and we'll have maybe some of
the questions i will
read them out loud and have the the
panelists answer them
so this is so important to have a
concern that
so i i have concerned myself so when
they want me to think sign concept i'd
see i want to send concept
that my data will be used for your
research but for any
other research that will come in the
future because
at least this will serve some the
research
and everybody in my situation is
thinking exactly the same
so we have to think that constant is
very important and we
we should take care of that and also
there's another point that is uh
people are not thinking of taking care
of
keeping the data if you are in the
services
service central services
not only uh emergency rooms
emergency room the data from the
emergency room so a person within the
emergency room has
a lot of machine that is plugging on him
and there's a lot of data that's
scattered
and now it's what's 73 two hours after
that
they are deleting the data and this
from the point of view of a discovery
true hey hi
this is bad news i would say
better data better discovery that brings
us to the third question
how do you see the impact of fusing
those digital discovery
either within clinical trial research or
clinical application so who wants to uh
take a stab at it i can start if you
want and
it will also also have a link with the
previous discussion
we just had one second ago
i think it's important to marry the
technology solution
to the uh content solution to the
to the overall what is the problem we're
trying to solve and
how this will help us solve the problem
uh and one of the thing which is
happening right now is that we're moving
very strongly towards
to to managing healthcare trajectory
as as opposed to managing episodes of
of care and and that kind of stuff and
frankly i think this will help the ai
from different angles because as we're
bringing that together
they will start to emerge some consensus
on what's the best approaches and
it won't be perfect but but there'll be
some some movement towards what is the
best approach
to martin previous point there will be
some kind of consensus and then
we'll be able to move with that
knowledge and and improve that knowledge
so
i think there there's an incidence on
that the the other thing that this is
forcing
us to do i think is to a little bit
start with the end in mind so what is
the problem we're trying to solve for
that l trajectory
and consequently this will position the
ti tools
uh in a much better light to some
because there will be the full benefit
of having the ai tool
but there also will also be the benefit
of seeing what is the potential impact
on the healthcare system
and on the patient so i i think those
points are
a little bit different maybe but they're
taking us towards
a convergence that needs to happen and
will help ai
and ai solutions that wants to get
implemented
i would really like anxious to hear your
your top as a ceo of a very large
hospital
i know we're just starting but he's a
knife enlighten us
i think there is uh two things that we
have to
consider the first is to use artificial
intelligence
in solving a research uh
question can you hear me it's okay
all good yeah okay that's the first one
and then you can use that to uh define
uh according to your hypothesis your
question
your research question how we you can
use ai
as a new method of developing research
we had rcts before we had
a different kind of basic research
translational research so it's it's a
new way
and it has to be properly defined
like real world research and
made to position ai research
with the other methods the second point
is ai and the data issued from
ai analysis can provide us with new
questions
for research and that is something that
we
we didn't think before when we were
using
a research tool which was probably
developing new questions according to
the initial question
ai analysis of data can generate
new questions that were not related to
the
initial question at all let's say you
follow a patient population and you will
describe
some will discover with ais that some
links
between genomics or imaging
or therapeutic response or
other factors will
define new knowledge a new question
issued from the ai analysis
so it's not a tool to do research
based on a human question by the
researchers
is generating a new question of research
by artificial intelligence if we were
uh thinking about what we described
before in terms of barriers
and overcoming barriers to use
artificial intelligence
we have to get the researchers prepared
to the fact that they
maybe will have ai generated
question and hypothesis that they were
not thinking of before
so what will be the response to that how
will they manage this question
generated by ai and how will they then
use ai or other form of research
to validate uh the the question
asked by ai analysis
so that is something that uh when you
use for instance
your platform evidence and when you look
at data that
are issued from different data bank or
data lake then you will see new things
that will occur
and we'll ask the researcher new
questions
and that is something that we are
experiencing now
you know that we have our lakes that we
call citadel
and uh our director of research called
that
citadel with the new generation
by ai question and then
how will we implement this
new question in our research uh
protocol or strategy that's probably one
first thing that i would say answering
your question
thank you uh fabrice and just to
emphasis on on citadel we we always
think oh in the hospital they have
50 systems maybe 100 system action i
think you have 309 systems
so the work of citadel to aggregate some
of those data
was was paramount and very important
same work that they
they are doing at shuk so when you want
to do artificial intelligence
it's not magic you need also to get
organized internally so those are
key initiatives i see one question
relevant in the q a
regarding those discoveries
what do you do with them so some of
those discovery
will be on the regulated path some
others
won't be it really depends on what you
want to do with them
that could be a full topic but health
canada was
really helpful and have actually done a
consultation
in revising their medical device as a
software
class to get input from artificial
intelligence
company so um i think we're in a good
hands in canada making sure that we can
bring
those discoveries in various flavors
uh last intervention on this on this
question before we move to the
last one
okay i i think you are exactly
the the subject about research is about
interpretability in ai and and of course
there are two reasons why
interpretability is important in in
healthcare
uh the first one is if you want to have
ai
in in in the media
precision medicine then you the
adi system has to explain to the
the specialist why he proposed
pills blue instead of feels green this
is the first thing that is
obvious but also in the research part
interpreters
interpretability is so important because
ai is looking for correlation
we try to go to causality but it's a
much more difficult uh
way to do that so we we infer
in a hypothesis from the data so it's
it's exactly the converse as
what is usually science we start from
the data and we infer hypothesis
normally the research is doing exactly
the converse
right and and so when we look at the
data we need to
see where are the correlation and we
need to be able to explain it
to the researcher say well i think that
this
uh mutation at this gene
as an important role for this phenotype
is it known and and then the specials
will say yes we know that
since 20 years because we have been oh
or
they will say whoa we don't know and
when ai is finding such
a hypothesis that is not known
there are two possibilities the ai may
be not correct
it can do errors or is going to
in a direction to have a new finding a
new discovery in that
in that direction and this back and
forth
between research in medicine
and ai is one of the reason why i think
that
medicine of precision medicine will be
the next
very important breakthrough of ai
we have um the autonomous car
we have the image recognition we have
the understanding of natural language i
think the next step
of the big big exploit
that will cfai will be in medicine
precision
for that reason and thus ties into the
treatment response some patients will
respond very well to some type of
treatment
if you have a 30 response rate on a
treatment you want to know
are you going to respond to that
treatment or you're better on the second
one
i experienced this myself firsthand and
it's always a tough choice
when you don't know the the outcome um
there's also a question on the q a
regarding digital discoveries so where
the data comes from if you have very
old data but you have a lot of them is
that relevant
whether or not you have consent so i
already answered the question of consent
i would say typically we want recent
data
because working on data that date 15
years or even
older than 10 years equipment change
treatment change
so it's important to have a variability
in the the duration of your data
because you want to follow the
progressions
of the disease and how the patient
evolved but sometimes having data
40 years old is of course less relevant
than
current data so that's just a small
clarification
if i may just add a very very brief
comment uh
in in response to what we would do with
digital discoveries
as a researcher i can tell you we would
embrace it and
we already are you know basing a lot of
our hypotheses
based on previous projects that we're
doing very
as we plan to do it and then along the
way we go what is this what
what is that and then and then this
triggers on new research projects so
we're already influenced by the data we
get so
i can certainly foresee that we will
embrace
insight will be provided from
discoveries from ai
thank you martin for the last question
um and we'll leave few minutes for the
the last q a on the
chat always
what are the most pressing need where do
you see ai discovery
could be applied and have big impact we
don't know when they come there's
already
some ai discoveries in the market but i
really want to
to hear you maybe starting by by fabrice
i i think there is this is a very
important question
alexander the problem is
we have so many fields
of application of artificial
intelligence
data analysis or artificial
intelligence decision making help
that it's very difficult to prioritize
i would say we we have two different
uh fields the first one is
what francois called before precision
medicine
or individualized medicine
in which you can use data and the result
of the data analysis
with your machine learning training as
you said before
to better treat a given patient
or a [ __ ] of isolated or identified
group of patients so i think this is
a very rich environment in which you can
get
a lot of application of ai tools
to better treat better diagnosed and
follow up the patients the second
part is much more related to the health
of the individual or the population
and if you are looking at this second
field
it's it's huge it's uh almost uh without
any barriers because uh it's uh the sum
of
uh personal personal i mean
uh genomics and and uh individual
based uh prognosis and in health
uh determinants plus all the
environmental factors and we see that
with the covet for instance today
with the pandemic we see that uh our
major concern is to keep
our population safe and healthy
according to their susceptibility
individual susceptibility but also the
environmental
factors we have developed uh different
tools to see the influence of
uh socio-economic factors where the
the people live what is their uh
their habits in terms of
socialization and and all of these
factors that will increase the risk
so in that case ai could be extremely
useful
because we will have more and more data
to deal with
and to make the decision based on a
huge amount of data uh maybe full data
that are uh much more than
in precision medicine in which we can
focus on on the disease and the
treatment
and and and that will also be a much
more
uh important when you have this health
approach and not the disease approach
in terms of what we discussed in your
first question which is
uh confidentiality privacy
because you are not leading with our
the patient we are in fact dealing
not leading but dealing with citizens
that are healthy that you want to keep
healthy
so in that case what is privacy
confidentiality personal rights
democracy is completely different as if
you
speak about precision medicine
in which the patients need to have more
and more information about the way to be
diagnosed prognose and treated and
if you look at all the surveys that have
been made the patients are much more
in agreement with using ai than the
citizens
this is uh this is something that i
think
uh needs some debate in the society
but yeah in a research we call it the
exposure
instead of at simply re regarding for
example the genome of the person
or the clinical data we we look at
everything that happened to the citizen
so this means for example that
they have a fitbit watch and so we
we take all these data together
and we use the fact that
ai is good as taking a terrorist reduce
data that are very unstructured
like sensors data and combined with
natural language data such as a report
or an email combined with
genomic data combined with whatever
right ai is very good to combine
everything on that
and so if we can have access to a lot of
such
information for a lot of citizens then
we will be able to help
people to to to be in to to to be to be
preserve their health
but i think we are not there yet no
because of the privacy problem that you
you you said
but uh this is something i hope
will be the the next step
there's an interesting question in the q
a from joseph
viviano i will read it out loud and i
think francois you could provide some
insight
what do the end user the physician
consider sufficient model
interpretability
for regulatory approval is it an op it
is an open debate
on a medical side what constitutes an
importable
an interpretable model so certainly
under regulatory
there's clinical trial digital discovery
will follow the same path so no product
will will see the light that has not
been approved if it's on the regulatory
path but i want to have your
your your thought process francois what
constitute a sufficient interpretable
model
yeah first thing first i don't believe
even if it's my job two for two to to
work on that
i don't believe that each a possible ai
will be
one day interpretable some some
some tasks need a very very complicated
deep learning network on which we will
barely be able to
give good insight and so
interpretability is not defined properly
yet
we know that we achieve some
interpretability level
when we achieve it and there is some
metric now that we are
trying to define in in this direction
and stuff like that
but uh at the moment there is no
um there is no way to say that
and ai is interpretable enough to
be certified by uh uh
come the authorities
we have the same problem with with
airplanes for example
we'll leave the question canon ai
certified another ai model for the next
uh presentation but i think that's a
very interesting
panel i see a lot of uh unanswered
question in the q a
uh for those of you that have the q a
i'll stay later and answer some of those
on the chat
um i really want to thank all the
panelists
um francois martin paul fabrice
i think we could have continued the
discussion for another hour
and i think together we are making a
difference
so thanks fabriz for supporting our
deployment at shum
martin for supporting our deployment at
shus and francois for
supporting our deployment in shuk and
paul
hopefully to initiate that innovation
movement that you've
started uh not that long ago but times
fly
and lisa it's always a pleasure to uh to
work with you
since the last five years so we'll
conclude this uh
session and again uh thanks to our host
uh
novartis
[Music]
on the call um
okay so regarding uh the agreement
to onboard various collaborators and
manage their numerous
requirements maybe i'll let you go alex
so the question
came from anne mcdowell so the the
the agreement that we make with the
hospitals it's a mastery agreement
and we want to make sure that each
project is well represented but it's an
iterative project
process so let's say the first project
that is on boarded
require images and reports
so this is what is typically yet
integrated as part of the
uh of the integration if there's another
project that required genomic data
at a panel level that's the next thing
that's going to be
integrated so we never integrated the
300 system
at once unless you have something like a
data lake
uh for example that you have action so
the uh the advantage of having such an
agreement with the institution
everything goes by amendment and you
don't need to revisit
the whole strategy every time you add
another project so that was the question
from
anne mcdowell the quest the question
from joseph i think
francois provides a nice explanation
um we already have a question
regarding old data uh so i answer that
live i think we need to emphasis on
the type of data that we're getting as
well it's important to get
data that are consumed by human but
sometimes we lack
the raw data that produce those i would
say
filter data so we're not there yet but
it's really important to keep that in
mind that a lot of equipment
generate raw data that we never see and
of course there's more signal in those
raw data
then there's another question on ethics
about patient decision can a patient
do can consent this can consent that
there's an important concept of patient
withdrawal
consent so a patient can change their
mind
if they're not happy about the decision
they've made in the past
they can redraw their consent and that's
a very important
piece of the puzzle that you want to
maintain at all time
and this is called traceability we want
to make sure that we
maintain data traceability at all time
so if a patient revokes it
it's consent we can remove the data
from the research environment but also
remove a model that would have learned
from that
specific data and retrain it live
of course when the model is in the
market like a pill
uh the consent cannot be redraw for this
specific
commercial outcome but it will be
effective for any new
research so uh i would argue that
traceability
can be as important or even more
important than
confidentiality so thank you lisa we'll
we'll close the the session
now thank you everyone alexander
thanks everyone bye